y llegó el momento de hablar con nuestro
segundo invitado del día y el tema tiene
que ver con el pedido del presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro al presidente
del gobierno español Pedro Sánchez la
semana pasada para que con su mediación
pueda ayudar a la guerrilla del eln a
salir de las listas de organizaciones
terroristas de los países de la Unión
Europea ahora que España presidirá el
consejo europeo el próximo semestre para
el análisis saludamos en Bogotá a Luis
Eduardo Celis analista de temas de paz y
de conflicto armado y además asesor de
la fundación paz y Reconciliación en
Colombia señor sales bienvenida directo
América primero qué supondría la salida
del eln de estas listas de en las que se
les clasifica como organizaciones
terroristas que cambiaría por ejemplo
Andrés Buen día para ti y para toda la
audiencia de veinticuatro Muchas gracias
por esta oportunidad de diálogo sobre
los temas de Colombia Bueno estamos el
gobierno del presidente Petro lidera una
negociación con la última de las
guerrillas de este viejo alzamiento
armado como lo es el eln es importante
que esta negociación vaya hacia adelante
en ese contexto el pedido del presidente
Petro al presidente Pedro Sánchez para
que el eln sea sacado de la lista de
regiones terroristas de la Unión Europea
pues es un gesto político una señal de
la buena voluntad que le asiste a este
gobierno y sería un mensaje de la Unión
Europea que de hecho varios países como
es la misma España Suecia y Alemania ya
son digamos los países acompañantes de
esta negociación reconociendo que le
leen ese una organización Rebelde en
armas que tiene una agenda política y
con la cual se puede lograr un acuerdo
de paz que es muy importante para
Colombia se sabe por ejemplo Qué
factores se considerarían a la hora de
tomar una decisión como estas de sacarlo
de estas listas de organizaciones
terroristas
Bueno hasta donde yo tengo entendido no
hay criterios ni para ni para entrar ni
para salir de la lista creo que de hecho
no hay no hay mucha especificación de
cómo saca una una organización que ha
sido incluida el eln fue incluido por en
esta lista por solicitud del presidente
pastrana al final de su mandato en el
solicitud que si no estoy mal se le
presentó al presidente aznar de España
para que quedara vinculada el elen en
esta lista y así fue Entonces yo creo
que es una decisión política y ojalá que
la Unión Europea en su momento considere
esa decisión que sería un mensaje de
apoyo a una negociación de paz que es
importante para Colombia vimos Durante
este encuentro en España con el
presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez como este mandatario casi que
evitó comprometerse a la solicitud del
presidente Gustavo Petro podríamos decir
aquí que esta no respuesta es también
una respuesta
Yo creo que
el presidente Pedro Sánchez hace bien al
actuar con calma y pedir prudencia en
ese en esa decisión de de Cuándo se hará
esa solicitud formalmente por parte de
de España que es lo que ha pedido el
presidente Petro que España haga esa ese
favor a Colombia también hay que
entender que es un tema delicado para
para el gobierno español donde hay una
sensibilidad en la sociedad española con
esos términos de terrorismo no con toda
esa triste historia afortunadamente en
el pasado de lo que fue esta que yo pues
eso fue un gran debate en la sociedad
española entonces hay que esperar con
prudencia y esperar el momento para que
ese trámite se pueda hacer usted lo
mencionaba hace un momento Nosotros
también actualmente se llevan a cabo
conversaciones entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln pero
esta solicitud que hace el presidente
Gustavo Petro facilitaría de algún modo
este proceso de negociaciones
sin duda o sea sin duda si la Unión
Europea toma la decisión de de sacar al
eln de esa lista de de terrorismo pues
es un es un espaldarazo al proceso de
paz el eln es una organización que se
mantiene en una rebelión política de un
viejo conflicto Por supuesto que en
algunos momentos eh sus actuaciones
pueden ser tildadas de terroristas pero
en su conjunto es una violencia política
eh
compleja en la sociedad colombiana por
supuesto censurable como todas las
violencias y que hay que superar pero
sin duda que un gesto de la Unión
Europea de sacarlos de la lista de
terroristas sería un un espaldarazo a
este a este esfuerzo Hola señor Celis un
informe del centro de recursos para el
análisis del conflicto dice que abril
fue el mes que mostró mayor número de
acciones ofensivas del eln en lo que va
de 2023 Qué implicaciones tendría
sacarlo de una lista de organizaciones o
de una lista que lo considera como
organizaciones terroristas en medio de
una situación como esta
Bueno yo creo que tenemos un conflicto
vivo el eln es un organizamiento
permanece en doscientos municipios de
los mil cien que tenemos
permanece fácilmente en 17 departamentos
de los 42 que tenemos es una fuerza
guerrillera con una actividad constante
y eso es lo que hay que superar
precisamente eso es lo que hay que
superar y por eso estamos sentados en
este momento en la Habana con el
liderazgo del gobierno colombiano con
esa organización para para salir de la
única forma que es posible mediante un
acuerdo negociado entonces lo que dice
el crack es cierto hay una actividad
permanente de de este de esta guerrilla
así como lo hay hay una actividad
permanente de parte de la fuerza pública
colombiana hacerse un conflicto vivo que
hay que superar y esperemos que este
ciclo de la Habana salga una dinámica de
distensión con un cese bilateral y sobre
todo con un acuerdo sobre participación
de la sociedad que es el corazón de este
proceso este proceso requiere mucha
participación de la sociedad para
construir ese acuerdo
ahora qué obstáculos podrían surgir en
este camino de negociaciones entre entre
el gobierno y el eln
Bueno yo creo que por ahora Estamos en
la en la en la idea de que se abra una
dinámica de participación se logre un
cese bilateral se logre un horizonte de
transformaciones a corto mediano y largo
plazo como lo establece la agenda de
México que es la la hoja de ruta de este
proceso y las dificultades pues se se
tendrán que sortear en una sociedad
donde hay una un sector fuerte que no
quiere cambios que no quiere cambios en
las regiones que no quiere ampliar esa
precaria democracia que no quiere
reconocer responsabilidades entonces con
seguridad que vamos a tener dificultades
pero son dificultades que habrá que
sortear Señores hoy en día Cuál es la
percepción de los colombianos sobre este
proceso de negociaciones
Bueno yo creo que la gente que sufre
este conflicto en los doscientos
municipios tiene el anhelo de que esto
avance o sea siempre recordar que en
este conflicto Hay muertos hay
desplazamientos Hay personas heridas Hay
personas que sufren esta violencia
permanentemente y de ahí la importancia
de salir de esta violencia
en el mundo urbano tal vez esto es un
tema lejano No pero en el mundo rural
donde se sufre es un tema que está en la
piel de las personas y de las
comunidades ahora volviendo al tema
central de esta discusión que es este
pedido que le hizo el presidente Gustavo
Petro al presidente del gobierno español
Pedro Sánchez para que de alguna forma
me haga una mediación para poder sacar
al Elena estas listas Qué implicaciones
tendría
o cómo se tomaría esto en territorio
colombiano Cómo impactaría esta decisión
en territorio colombiano
bueno para los que pensamos que la única
salida es un esfuerzo de paz negociada
con transformaciones con cambios eh que
la Unión Europea saque el eln es un un
respaldo importante insisto en que hay
tres países de la Unión Europea que
acompañan esta negociaciones España
Suecia y Alemania Entonces ya digamos
los hay una avanzada de países europeos
que dan respaldo y muchos otros están
interesados en que esta negociación
avance Entonces yo creo que el sacar al
eln está lista sería un mensaje de apoyo
de la Unión Europea y bueno tendría
también consecuencias prácticas Se
podrían hacer reuniones del eln en la
Unión Europea o en países de la Unión
Europea sin sin este hoy son inviables
no por ser parte de esa lista claro Luis
Eduardo Celis analizada de temas de paz
y de conflicto armado y asesor de la
fundación paz y Reconciliación en
Colombia Gracias por acompañarnos en el
análisis aquí en directo América
no Andrés gracias a ti y al Canal atrás
24 y buena semana buena semana para
usted también y de esta manera
despedimos este bloque Informativo en
directo América quédense con nosotros
Porque minutos regresamos con más
[Música]